le salon filiale de sang dans l'aude a
ouvert ses portes ce matin et nombreux
sont ceux à avoir jeté l'ancré si dans
ce premier port fluvial de france ce
salon est à l'initiative de communauté
de communes rives de saône avec un
objectif dépasser le cap des 6000
participants
premier invité de marque le soleil la
garantie pour les organisateurs que les
visiteurs fouleront les allées du salon
mais il ne comptait pas que sur lui pour
atteindre leurs objectifs de
fréquentation on a fait cette année un
effort particulier de la promotion du
salon dans des revues spécialisées en
angleterre ou aux pays bas et en suisse
pays d'où proviennent beaucoup des
touristes qui fréquentent saint jean de
losne
il faut savoir saint jean de losne est
connu à l'étranger jusqu'en nouvelle
zélande en australie et moins en france
car les français sont encore peu
nombreux à naviguer alors pour la
soixantaine d'exposants présents mieux
vaut maîtriser l'anglais john oui oui on
connaît on a lu beaucoup au sujet de ce
salon à travers des blocs de
spécialistes et des vivres
c'est un site très répertoriés ils ont
un sens et un quart pour janvier
parmi les quelques français présents
joël à quelques années de la retraite il
est venu chercher des conseils en vue
d'acheter un bateau et je suis tombé
d'ailleurs ceux des personnes très
sympathiques très accueillante et qui
collabore facilement en fait ils
communiquent les informations très
précieuses facilement et c'est ça que
j'apprécie ce genre de relation
dans le monde fluvial car la navigation
est un secteur en vogue le tourisme de
plaisance ses 10 millions de passagers
par an des formations et des emplois à
la clé que vous soyez un marin d'eau
douce chevronnés ou simples visiteurs
vous l'aurez compris vous êtes les
bienvenus ici l'entrée se fait sur 7
jusqu'à demain à 18 heures et c'est
gratuit